ALL RIGHT, SIDNEY, THANKS FOR
ALL YOU DO.
WE NEED A BETTER JUSTICE SYSTEM.
REPUBLICANS MOVE FORWARD ON
ANOTHER ROUND OF STIMULUS TO GET
DIRECT PAYMENTS TO THE HANDS OF
FAMILIES.
NANCY PELOSI, CHUCK SCHUMER,
GUESS WHAT, THEY DON’T REALLY
CARE.
THEY JUST ONCE AGAIN RESORTING
TO PETTY POLITICS, WANTING TO
STOP THE PACKAGE JUST LIKE THEY
DID THE LAST TIME WITH A BLUE
STATE WISH LIST HERE AND HERE TO
EXPLAIN MORE, HOUSE MINORITY
LEADER KEVIN McCARTHY.
FIRST OF ALL, THEY WANT
$3 TRILLION.
SECONDLY, THEY WANT PEOPLE TO
MAKE MORE MONEY, STAYING
UNEMPLOYED THEN BEING EMPLOYED,
IS THAT CORRECT?
BY THE WAY, THE DEMOCRATS WANT
TO PROTECT CHINA FROM LIABILITY?
>> WELL, BUT THEY FIRST WANT TO
DO IS NO LONGER $3 TRILLION BUT
NOW $4 TRILLION.
REMEMBER THE $3 TRILLION BILL,
THEY MENTION CANDIDATES MORE
THAN EVER MENTIONED RESEARCH OUR
JOBS.
THIS IS WHAT THEY HAVE.
THEY JUST HAVE A WISH LIST AND
NOT A WAY FORWARD.
EVEN TODAY WHEN YOU HAVE
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE, THE
EXTRA AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT THE
THE GOVERNMENT PUTS INTO EXTENT
TO A WEEK WHILE WE NEGOTIATE,
YOU KNOW WHO SAID NO?
CHUCK SCHUMER.
BUT WATCH WHAT THEY WILL SAY ON
TELEVISION.
THE PRESIDENT WAS WILLING TO
CONTINUE TO GO FORWARD TO
PROTECT THOSE WHO ARE UNEMPLOYED
RIGHT NOW, SO WE CAN GET PEOPLE
WORKING AGAIN, AND SOLVE THIS
PROBLEM.
EVERY SINGLE TIME WE WORK ON
COVID LEGISLATION, YOU KNOW WHO
HAS HELD IT UP?
NANCY PELOSI.
REMEMBER AT HER REFRIGERATOR
WHEN SMALL BUSINESSES NEEDED THE
MONEY FOR EMPLOYEES?
SHE SAID NO.
THE VERY FIRST CARE’S ACT WENT
FORWARD, SHE SAID NO AND HELD IT
FOR ANOTHER WEEK.
HOW MANY MORE PEOPLE WERE
UNEMPLOYED BECAUSE OF
NANCY PELOSI AND CHUCK SCHUMER’S
ACTIONS.
IT IS UNBELIEVABLE.
>> Sean: WHAT ELSE IS HIDDEN
IN HERE?
LINDSEY GRAHAM SAID ON THE RADIO
SHOW AND IN FACT, THEY ACTUALLY
EXCEPT FOR ONE DEMOCRAT, THEY
WANT TO PERMIT AMERICANS THAT
WANT TO HOLD CHINA RESPONSIBLE
FOR WHAT THEY DID TO THE WORLD
FROM DOING SO.
WHY ARE THEY PROTECTING CHINA?
>> THAT IS THE BIGGEST QUESTION.
I DO NOT KNOW WITH THE COMMUNIST
PARTY OF CHINA HAVE ON THE
DEMOCRATS, BUT IT IS VERY
POWERFUL.
IT IS SO POWERFUL THAT WHEN THE
CHINESE ARE NOW HACKING TO FIND
OUR VACCINE, I PUT A BOW ON THE
FLOOR TO SANCTION ANY HACKER.
THEY VOTED AGAINST IT.
AND NOW IN THE COURT TODAY AND
FBI SAID CHINA IS INTO INFLUENCE
THE ELECTION AND WE KNOW WHO
THEY WANT TO WIN.
AND ALSO INFLUENCE MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS.
THEY DENIED THAT IN FOREIGN
AFFAIRS VOTE THE OTHER DAY.
WE EVEN HAVE THE ARMED SERVICE
CHAIRMEN SAY IT WASN’T CHINA’S
FAULT.
IT’S NOT THE RESPONSIBILITY TO
WARN AMERICA ABOUT THE VIRUS,
TRYING TO BLAME THE PRESIDENT.
ADAM SCHIFF, A REAL FAVORITE OF
ALL OF US.
YOU KNOW WHAT HE SAID WHEN THEY
CLOSE DOWN THE CONSULATE?
THE HUB OF ESPIONAGE?
HE SAID IT WAS ALL POLITICS AND
HE BLAMED AMERICA.
WHY WON’T NANCY PELOSI BRING
THOSE BILLS TO THE FLOOR THAT
HOLD THEM ACCOUNTABLE?
WHY?
THEY WANT TO DEFEND CHINA AND
BLAME AMERICA.
>> Sean: WELL, THERE IS AN
ELECTION IN 96 DAYS.
I’M HOPING AND PRAYING THAT IF
YOU’RE GOING TO VOTE FOR THE
PRESIDENT, MAY BE AT TIME TO PUT
NANCY PELOSI IN THE MINORITY AND
KEEP THE SENATE REPUBLIC.
THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL.
>> THAT IS THE BEST THING YOU
CAN DO.
SO WHAT YOU GOT TO DO IS WHICH
PARTY IS BEST TO KEEP AMERICA